I think Scotland will become independent
my view is that that is the direction of
travel but on the question of timing for
the last 12 months I've been seeing very
clearly that I don't think it's right to
consider that decision where things are
so unclear and uncertain around breaks
it so as First Minister I won't give
consideration to the timing until we've
got some breaks at clarity the message I
was given to my party at our conference
yesterday is that that gives us an
opportunity not to worry all the time
about when we might vote again on
Independence but instead to engage in
the substance of the arguments and to
address people in Scotland who still ask
why we should be independent and I think
that debate is timely because there's
going to be change breaks it makes that
inevitable most people think breaks that
will meet the country tutor so this is
an opportunity to look at whether
there's a better alternative for
Scotland and focus on hope and optimism
and how we maximize our potential as a
country so that's the opportunity I was
encouraging my party to grasp but when I
spoke to them yesterday so pretty clear
then that you say that there needs to be
a bit more bricks that clarity until we
get more clarity about a referendum on
Scotland so let's talk about brexit
shall we because in 2016 after that
referendum you said that you were
looking at ways to keep Scotland in the
single market even if the UK leave so
how is that going well we are exploring
all options to protect Scotland's
interests I also said in 2016 and I
still see this today that the best
option for the whole of the UK if it's
leaving the EU which I regret is to stay
in the single market and the customs
union and I happen to think that there
is still a real prospect of securing
that it might not feel like that just
now when the Prime Minister is always
ruling it out but we only have to look
at the debated cabinet I do yes and
we'll see how the votes cool in the
House of Commons this week but even
beyond that I do think that is still a
reasonable prospect because the Prime
Minister's position is I think just
undeliverable and unsustainable she's
trying to reconcile all sorts of things
that are Eric and sale
and the common-sense solution as well as
I guess the best Democratic compromise
given the divisions of opinion around
BRICS is to stay in the single market
and the customs union so I don't think
there is any reason to give up on that
argument right now well that seems
remarkably optimistic given that both
the Conservative Party and labour are
saying that they are not looking for a
single market membership do you think
that something could be on the cards
like what is happening with the Irish
situation and the EU said that they're
looking into a bespoke agreement to
solve the problem of the border in
Northern Ireland is that something that
you could envisage happening for
Scotland a bespoke solution well one of
the reasons why I don't think we should
give up on customs union and single
market membership is that that is the
simplest way to resolve the issues in
Northern Ireland and resolve the issues
around the border between the north and
the Republic of Ireland so you know it's
not an ideal scenario but I'm just
trying to get to you know the reality of
the situation could you be arguing for
something bespoke for Scotland well if
there is a sport arrangement for
Northern Ireland and again I've said
this all along that keeps the Northern
Ireland in or effectively in the single
market then I do think it becomes all
the more important that those options
are open to Scotland because if we find
ourselves outside the single market
which would be damaging and a whole host
of ways anyway but Northern Ireland is
still and then Scotland would find
itself economically at a competitive
disadvantage and that would have
implications for jobs and investments in
Scotland so I think it stands to reason
that is First Minister I would be
arguing for similar options for Scotland
but I come back to my original point I
think it's right for the whole of the UK
to remain in the single market and the
customs union jobs depend on that
investment depend on that living
standards depend on that and I don't
think we should simply accept the
meltdown that is coming to use the
Foreign Secretary's language if the
Prime Minister and the government
continue to argue a position that is not
deliverable you know treason is spending
all of our time trying to keep our
cabinet together talking about options
that unite them I'm not sure whether
she's going to succeed even in that but
the options there top
have already effectively been ruled out
by the EU we need to see some realism
emerge in these discussions and that's
why I do think we've seen labour shift I
think on the customs union I think we
may see them shift more on single market
membership I think this is a moment for
those of us who believe in these
outcomes to continue to argue the case
for them
you're very critical that about Tereza
Mazar stance do you have a look at the
other people around the cabinet table
and feel a degree of relief that it's
her doing the negotiations rather than
for example Boris Johnson or David Davis
well yeah I mean I don't think Boris
Johnson should be anywhere near a
government office you know he must be at
one of the least fit people to hold a
high office of state that we've ever
seen and I thought that before his
comments at the end of last week he's
entirely playing to a heart breaks a
tear gallery it sounds as if Boris
Johnson fights it sounds as if none of
the members of the Thule cabin actually
care about jobs and living standards and
prospects for people the length and
breadth of the UK and that's got to
change and if the cabinet the Prime
Minister are not prepared to change and
argue for a more realistic and sensible
position then I hope we see the House of
Commons forced them into that position
now well we see what happens this week
I'm not seeing him I'm holding my breath
or being overly optimistic but sooner or
later there has to be an outbreak of
common sense and I hope we see that
sooner rather than later I'm talking
about those comments that Boris Johnson
made her one of them was that Donald
Trump might make a better job of the
brexit negotiations he of course has
been ripping up every piece of
diplomatic protocol at the g7 will you
be welcoming him to Scotland when it
comes to visit well we don't know his
plans yet you know I think everybody
knows that I don't see eye to eye with
Donald Trump on very many things of
course if the President of the United
States comes to Scotland and there's an
opportunity to engage with them as first
minister of course I will do that but
you know how many very clear the values
and principles that are important to me
to my government I think too many people
across Scotland and I think in this
uncertain what would we live in right
now it's important to speak up for the
progressive principles those values of
social democracy and I think the more
politicians we hear doing that the
better now before you go I've got to ask
you the World Cup is starting next week
unfortunately Scotland not playing a
part in it so are you gonna be cheering
for jokes
I wish include well in the World Cup
maybe if they win this world cup we can
stop talking about 1966 at long last but
as I was seen in another interview at
the end of the week I drew Iceland in my
office sweepstakes so I'll be keeping an
eye out on their scores as well
okay very diplomatic Leon Verdi Nicola
Sturgeon thanks very much